a dormant volcano in iceland has come
back to life for the first time in
nearly
800 years the night sky lit up near the
capital reykjavik late on friday
the eruption came after thousands of
small earthquakes in the region in
recent weeks
the area is a seismic hot spot and all
air traffic has been halted
iceland is home to europe's most active
volcanic region
so let's go to iceland's capital
reykjavik can bring in seismologist dr
thorberg augusto from iceland geosurvey
thanks for joining us
um what kind of threat level are we
looking at here is anybody's
life in danger
no not at the moment what we're looking
at is a very very small eruption
and this is a fish eruption so we um
last evening and throughout the night we
had some lava fountaining
um and you have some lava flowing as you
can maybe see in the pictures
but it's a very small eruption threat
levels are very low
and the experts are saying that this is
happening in the best possible place
excuse me best possible place in the in
the peninsula
regarding um infrastructure and people
so
at the moment since the eruption is very
small nobody is
uh in danger luckily
and the area of iceland where you are as
as you know
better better than anyone is listed as
one of the most seismologically
active areas in the world are you able
to learn anything from what's going on
now
yeah we're learning it by every hour um
so
as you mentioned it is 800 years since
we have the last eruption in this
peninsula
this eruption type is completely
different to what you experience in
2010 it will not close the european
airspace
for for a period of time firstly it's
very small the second
is it's a completely different type of
eruption
what we're learning is that we can have
a seismic activity
in this case outlining intruding magma
at depth
and then you can have the magma chose
this time to go
to the surface it could have stopped and
froze
the news from yesterday was was maybe is
it dying down or will we have an
eruption
um so you see what happened last night
we had the eruption
okay well listen um so it's quite
uncertain
in a way okay i think the last time
many of us paid attention to volcanoes
and iceland was in that
2010 event i'm going to try to say the
name of the volcano i think it was iaf
uh yokut uh correct me if i'm wrong
okay um how is this different what's
happening now how is this different from
then you were saying it's it's it's a
completely different type of event
yes so in obviously you could you had
this
more like a starter volcano you had a
glacier on top
you had a different chemistry in the
the magma which meant you had more
explosive activity
it was enhanced by the glacier so if the
hot melt
magma touching the um the ice
you will have an explosive eruption um
and that the chemistry of this
magma meant that it was very fine
grained
so it flew very far far with the with
the ash and the wind
and but in this case in reykjanes what
we have is a very small fish of eruption
it's only about 700 meters
it's flowing quite gently the lava
fountains
reached maximum 100 meters
yesterday evening and so it's completely
different you don't have a
10 kilometer eruption column so yeah
it's a totally different scenario but
it's um very beautiful
it is it is beautiful less spectacular
perhaps but
uh certainly still interesting to
observe
scientifically i'm sure dr thorberg
august daughter from reykjavik thanks so
much for that
no worries thanks
[Music]
do
[Music]
so the situation in gryndavik is quite
uncomfortable
right now everyone is sleep deprived
because the earth is constantly moving
all day all night some earthquakes are
bigger than
others some are 3.1 some are 4.2
today we had a big one 5.4
things fell down on the shelves in the
house
even though i had laid many things down
[Music]
right now it's about one kilometer depth
and
all of this pressure from the magma is
causing
a lot of earthquakes i think the
icelandic meteorological office has
recorded like 40 000 events
in about almost three weeks so it's a
pretty strong activity
and we've never seen anything like this
on reagan's before not in
written recorded history so it's a quite
unusual activity
[Music]
you